and it's become encouraged now
to feminize men if they want to feminize
their men they can do it but they're not
going to feminize our men stay within
reason doesn't mean we have to become
you know barbarians obviously not we
have to be sophisticated yet but manly
my children
i'll give you guys a quick anecdote one
of my sons on on valentine's day they
showed him a movie
a romantic movie and my son's 10 years
old about one guy falling in love with
another
so he comes home my kids they're open
book especially when we're driving to
the gym i let them talk to me about
anything so my son's like uh you know
watch this movie and two guys were
kissing each other so be my friend were
laughing and everybody got angry with us
because we were laughing
and they were telling me it's normal
it's normal it's normal they were
telling you that the kids the kids in
the class were like like why are you
laughing it's not right and
the teacher was telling my son oh it's
okay if you're gay
if you're gay you know like you could
say
me and my son
my sons my two sons were like that's
we're like that's pretty weird man
that's pretty weird these kids haven't
even gone through puberty yet i sent my
kid to school to learn math science
history philosophy uh you know ethics
you know the basics
why are you showing them on valentine's
day
a story about a man falling in love with
a man now listen there are
gay people in the world i tell my kids
look there are gay people you're gonna
see it but i said we're not gay
i thought i'm straight up and i'm not
ashamed i thought if you're a teacher
tell your teacher that i told him you're
heterosexual and if he has a problem
with that to call me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by the value of a dollar goes
lower and lower and lower and the reason
being is because they're printing more
money right that's why money is haram at
least the paper money is haram provided
that you're actually there and you're
being a good father and the mother's
being a good mother best conditions
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
welcome to the realist podcast in the
dunya with the three
[Music]
it's been a couple months since the last
target
yes yes a long long time man what's
changed uh in the meanwhile
uh
canada's been mad with the
with the covid the restriction fever and
uh just been a battle uh it's just been
been quite insane
but uh luckily the last few months we've
reopened the gym fully and things have
bounced back alhamdulillah and getting
things back on on the way on the way
perfect perfect before we go into
health fitness mma all that what do you
think are the two most important things
for men today
for men today um you know first get a
six-pack up here
and then worry about the six-pack down
here i feel like uh you know you should
have uh you know you should have uh time
for study and learning and time for
fitness but both are equally important i
think today the trend is being you know
physically fit but not so
uh educationally fit let's put it you
know i think both are supremely equally
important they both add to richness in
life being healthy but also being
mentally uh well uh well tutored i
should say
so that's one thing
what's the second thing
that was the second thing physical and
mental but i feel today people are too
much on the physical you know they just
want to be physical physical they have
instagram fever i try to avoid instagram
you know because it's just it's just i
mean so much pollution out there but
it's um
it's interesting you know but
it's equal it's actually a greater
experience or equally great i should say
i i don't want to
but to to also experience life in an
intellectual way it's supremely
important okay i think a multi-faceted
approach is what most men are lacking
today they're lacking this balance
so that being said what does masculinity
mean to you
i think masculinity is super important
but there is a there's a level of
masculinity that can become toxic so you
know you hear that term toxic
masculinity if you uh i don't know if
you sit down to too manly you're toxic i
don't i think there's a balance you want
to be manly but not too overly manly
like you shouldn't be spitting on the
floor and you know cursing everything
there's a healthy level of masculinity
which is important i think that the
mainstream
cultures are losing it they're losing it
fast
they're losing it fast
and it's become
encouraged now
to feminize men
and if they want to feminize their men
they can do it but they're not going to
feminize our men
uh we should uh you know stay within
reason doesn't mean we have to become
you know uh
barbarians obviously not we have to be
sophisticated yet but manly my children
i'll give you guys a quick anecdote one
of my sons on valentine's day they
showed him a movie
a romantic movie and my son's 10 years
old about one guy falling in love with
another
so he comes home my kids they're open
book especially when we're driving to
the gym i let them talk to me about
anything there's no
topic that they can't bring up
so my son's like uh you know watch this
movie and two guys were kissing each
other so being my friend were laughing
and that everybody got angry with us
because we were laughing
and they were telling me it's normal
it's normal it's normal they were
telling you the kids the kids in the
class were like like why are you
laughing it's not right and the teacher
was telling my son oh it's okay if
you're gay
if you're gay you know like you could
say
me and my son my sons and my two sons
were like that's we're like that's
pretty weird man that's pretty weird
these kids haven't even gone through
puberty yet i sent my kid to school to
learn math science history philosophy uh
you know ethics
you know the basics
why are you showing them on valentine's
day
a story about a man falling in love with
a man now listen there are
gay people in the world i tell my kids
there are gay people you're gonna see it
but i said we're not gay
i also i thought i'm straight up and i'm
not ashamed i thought if you're a
teacher
tell your teacher that i told him you're
heterosexual and if he has a problem
with that to call me
[Music]
i'm 100 serious i thought i said if he
does not have you the fact that you're
tell tell your tell your teacher look
him in the eye and tell him look i'm 100
heterosexual
i said use the term super straight i
tell them what the term superstreet is
and don't be shy about it all don't be
apologetic about it at all
tell them we're straight
and i tell my son you know why you're
straight
think about what if your father was gay
where would you be
you wouldn't exist
tell your teacher that there's something
special when a man and a woman fall in
love together you know what that special
thing is they create life
they create life so there's something
unique about when a man and woman get
together they can create life they
propagate life we think life is
beautiful i think the progeny is the
most important
they
have the western world has become i'm
the most important thing in the world so
whatever makes me happy
if i'm gay oh well that makes me happy
that's what i'm gonna do
the muslim world is saying no
the collective is the most important the
muslim body is the most important what's
the healthiest for us is to propagate
our our our progeny and teach them islam
and that is more important than me the
individual
and therefore i'm going to raise because
don't forget you can culturize we're
going to talk about yes some people
might be born gay yes that's true but
most a lot of it could be culturalized
and anybody want to debate me on this
please please do i can't wait to have
this debate uh the spartans it was
mandatory to be gay
the spartans you know people i'm a
spartan you sure you want to be a
spartan are you sure you want to be a
spartan it was mandatory to be
homosexual as a spartan
you can raise a child to be homosexual
like you could raise a child to be
heterosexual
now i'm not saying that it never happens
that you try to raise a child
heterosexual and he turns out to be
homosexual i'm not saying that i'm
saying by and large by enlarge and
listen to what i'm saying please don't
misquote me here
you can influence a child at a young age
to what sexual orientation he will have
i tell my sons i'm doing you guys the
biggest favor
i think i can do
and i'm teaching you to be heterosexual
you know why so you can do the greatest
thing
a human being can do in this dunya
is raise a family
now you tell me what's the greater
good
being in a relationship
with somebody of the same sex or
being in a relationship with opposite
sex and we could create a family nothing
is more important to me than my family
not my sexual my personal sexual life
my family is number one on every scope
except my religion there's my religion
then there's my family everything else
takes a place number three
now
when you're
propagating a homosexual culture you're
teaching your children to be gay you're
saying look
you the individual is more important
than the collective
okay that's your way of life i tell my
sons don't argue with them that's their
way of life that's fine
our way of life is us the collective is
more important than the individual if
you want to jump ship you think you're
more important the collective jump ship
but you're going to miss out on the
greatest human experience that in this
dunya you can have is a loving family
there's nobody that ever raised a
successful loving family that said you
know what i would trade this loving
family for this thing in the dunya or
this no there's no human being who ever
had a successful loving family he he he
sidestepped all the pitfalls
all the dangers that can hurt a family
i don't know if you guys noticed but
everything in islam that's haram is
harmful to a family and everything that
is halal helps the family grow i don't
know if you guys noticed but in the
quran everything that is forbidden
harms the family
how many millions of no how many
billions of children
have been saved from fetal alcohol
syndrome you know that women they drink
alcohol when they're pregnant and
oftentimes it's unknowingly they're
pregnant first trimester they're
drinking alcohol and they're are you
guys aware of fetal alcohol syndrome
how many m you know that when they do
studies on fetal alcohol syndrome they
exclude muslim countries
muslim countries have no fetal alcohol
there are no children
in islam and muslim countries
that are harmed by alcohol yet in the
west in other cultures
there is it's a major problem
i don't know if you guys are aware of
this
how many billions of people did the
koran save from fetal alcohol syndrome
everything that is haram in the quran
is bad for the family
now i tell my children
the family is first and then it's the
individual
this is our way of life this is what i'm
teaching you and i tell them that this
is going to bring you to a higher level
of happiness
and a closer relationship with
understanding your god
then if you put yourself first
and the family second then if you do
that in my opinion you're going to build
your own personal hell in this life and
in the next
a person who's in out for himself
it won't be long but we figure out that
person is a selfish member of this group
and he puts his interest before the
collective
and we're going to push him out of the
collective slowly and it's going to be a
type of uh
[Music]
difficult experience because every human
being
has a deep connect a deep desire for
belonging to a group you know adam
alaihi salam was in the garden of eden
yet he felt lonely he felt a weakness
he needed companionship we are all built
to connect with one another so the
ultimate connection is the human family
so i asked my sons where would you be if
i was gay
you wouldn't exist right checkmate i
tell them so the favor i did for you
the troubles i had raising a family the
sacrifices i made for this family to be
successful i expect you to pass it on
and do the same
and you're going to get an intrinsic
reward for it you can have a successful
family inshallah and if your peers want
to be gay that's their culture their
business their religion their
philosophies
and there's more women for us if they're
gay there's more women for us
don't argue with them don't fight with
them don't that's their prerogative
well that's it that's how i see it
that's how i tackle the
issue
i got i got ten percent battery here so
you gotta whip i got ten percent better
so i'm gonna throw
i'm gonna throw my questions out
all right man so
question number one
you have spoken about this before in
your podcast
uh
but in your opinion
what are the ranks
of all the martial arts if you had to
put it in like categories i think i
think the most fundamental and we're
talking about a fight here
like there's no time limit we're
fighting me and you're fighting until
one guy is finished yeah self defense
self defense we'll say that i would say
that ultimately
you need jiu jitsu because whether you
do kickboxing or wrestling it's very
hard to finish a jiu-jitsu guy
the only thing that beats jiu-jitsu is
jiu-jitsu mixed with something else
that's how i see it so i think you need
you don't need to be a black belt in
jiu-jitsu but you need to know some
level of jujitsu then you can mix it
with boxing or wrestling
or kickboxing or muay thai and then you
have even more powerful art but the most
fundamental martial art in my opinion is
jiu-jitsu then after that it's the
hybrids
after that is the what the hybrids the
mixture the mixed arts okay mixing two
arts together
the fundamental ingredient in my opinion
by and large if you put if you put a
hundred martial artists versus a hundred
jiu-jitsu guys the digital guys win
ninety percent of the time and i mean
this is we have ample evidence of this
i heard about that because when i was
training before i injured myself my
coach would always say like if you're
if you're fighting with someone and you
always striking
there's a there's a chance the other
person can get lucky and they can hit
you very like in the perfect spot at the
perfect time but if you're grappling
there's no chance that you're going to
get lucky it's all scary it's much less
likely yeah
it's just likely you fall into a
submission it's very
it's let's just say it's much less like
you're right absolutely that's a very
good point
all right so
with that being said
next question
uh
and this is something i've been kind of
playing with
just an idea but in your opinion because
you've been in this field for a very
long time now
alhamdulillah
you said or not you said but uh can
someone become truly well-versed in
self-defense
without ever training strikes to the
face or avoiding strikes to the face
um
you can't you can be very well versed
but in my opinion you will never be as
well versed as somebody who strikes also
to the face now
i think i have a feeling where you're
going with this it's hot on your face
i would say that look
look at that hadith was it talking about
sports training i don't think so to be
honest with you
um
i think it was referring to when you get
angry with somebody you're in a dispute
with somebody
no i'm not a i'm not a mufti like i'm
not an expert in
islamic law so forgive me you know my
domain is philosophy
but from what i can gather
it's you know if i get angry with you
and i slap you in the face that's
totally hot on there's no two ways about
it however if me and you are boxing and
we're practicing and i'm my attention is
not to hurt you but to learn how to
protect myself and train you and you
train me and we're having this uh i
don't think any shaq will say that
boxing training is haram i don't know if
there is but i i'm sure there are many
muftis that would say boxing training is
a different context
and as long as you're not trying to hurt
each other not trying to deface each
other like i box every single day pretty
much every single day and when i spar
it's like kind of touch sparring we call
it touch you know it's just playful
sparring it's not we're not hurting each
other we're not injuring each other it's
not a real strike per se it's a
controlled movement and
i i don't think that would be hard i
don't think any sheikh who sees what we
do and understands what we do with say
that's haram no that's with the
intention of
ameliorating ourselves and if we ever
have to defend our friends and family or
we ever have to
fight for whatever cause that's that's
fair uh we'd be ready for it
i mean uh i mean the sahaba trained
you know they trained they did train and
they were rough you know they were tough
they were very uh you know physical
um
so i think the equivalent of that if
they had the safety equipment we have if
they had the you know the arts we have i
think they would practice i'm not saying
they would compete in mma but i think
they would practice
the most
uh
practical arts and their boxing would
definitely be one of them
it makes sense
it makes sense
because i mean a lot of times when i try
to play with this idea
it's always just theoretical you know
what i'm saying like
when you get into a fight like
you could want to avoid strikes to the
face as much as possible
but that doesn't mean the other person
is
you know and if you've never trained to
avoid a strike to the face
you're probably gonna get hit in the
face yeah you know in martial arts we
have something called kyokushin where
they strike only to the body and then
when they convert later to boxing they
always have a hard time but quickly they
quickly catch up like for instance
george st pierre is uh you know uh
is one of the greatest probably the
greatest mma fighter in all time i know
him very well i've trained with him for
you know 20 years now he did striking to
the body for a very young age for a very
long time and semi-contact to the head
so very little
striking to the head let's put it that
way
and he became a world champion several
times over
but when we converted him to head
striking i mean there was a learning
period there's an adjustment period and
there are other
world champions they went through the
same path
but they caught up very quickly why they
know the distance they know the kicking
and punching they have everything except
there's an adjustment period so like my
kids i make them hit only to the body
no head strikes at all but as they get
older we're going to make that
adjustment so there is a need for it
there's definitely need for it but it
doesn't mean that
if you only strike to the body you're at
zero no no you can get to a very
adequate level but you won't get to an
elite level
unless you go straight to that you'd
have to be a very unique person to reach
elite level
without body strikes i would assume
without striking
to the head yeah yeah that makes sense
it makes sense 100
all right man so
another question i wrote them all down
because i had to i had to get my my
thoughts bro cool man so the next one is
uh
in one of your podcasts you had said
that when you train
uh you will do the martial arts and then
after the martial arts
you'll hit your set of pull-ups or you
might maybe a set of squats something
like that
how have you noticed the effectiveness
in that regard
versus like let's say structuring
uh a program where you have a specific
time frame geared for like okay i'm
gonna do a full body workout me twice a
week
versus oh i'm training martial arts
every single day maybe multiple times a
day but then i'm adding
so and so exercises after each
of my mma trainings
like period as puritizing right yeah
yeah
i think i think fitness has to be
complementary to your martial arts
skills so for instance
um it depends if i'm training you from
from a very young age if you're telling
me how to train this athlete he's five
years old and take him to a world
championship when he's in his 20s i
would say okay i would spend the first
few years on fitness
why i'm teaching him how to move his
body
how to lift how to push how to explode
how to side step i would teach him all
sorts of
i would teach him gymnastics track and
field i would spend my time on that
because before i if i before i teach him
the intricacies of how to throw a punch
he still doesn't even know how to move
his arm in a circle like he's very young
okay
i would start with the basics however
after a certain age
if you're 20 years old he let me train
this guy i could
spend two three years of training you
fitness
but
your potential to become a super athlete
is pretty much past
because if you didn't do athletics at a
very young age we're talking about
athletics not not physical looks okay
because you can you can go from uh
looking like a regular joe to a ripped
shredded donald schwarzenegger in in any
age at any age okay especially for
adding hormones to the to the recipe
okay so people take hormones
i'm talking about building world-class
skill in somebody that's a very
different topic
talking about like taking you to a world
championship in jiu jitsu or boxing and
winning
i would have to spend a lot of time in
that sport because it takes many years
to master the sport itself now i'm doing
it without first building you to be a
super athlete because training somebody
to become a super athlete in their 20s
is very difficult and you're running out
of time like when's he going to when
he's going to get his black belt in jiu
jitsu it takes 10 years so i like to
start with the martial art
as soon as possible if i'm training an
adult
and then after the workout after the
martial arts workout because martial
arts workout always first now we'll
bench press we'll squat we'll we'll
throw the med ball we'll go on the
rowing machine we'll do something
complimentary to enhance his athleticism
but just doing jiu jitsu or boxing is
already going to help me enhance his
athleticism
so i really feel like we need to do a
lot of both we need to do a lot of
conditioning and a lot of the sport
whatever your goal is you want to be a
boxer you want to be a thai guy you want
to be but you need to do
first things first the first thing is
the martial art
and then i do the fitness behind it
um there are various ways to approach
but i mean if you let's say i do five
rounds of sparring and then i go and i i
take a break i take a shake i relax and
i do i don't know 10 sets of deadlift i
think that's a very good combination why
i'm doing the sport
i'm making the sport second nature i'm
doing it every day i'm spending hours
and hours practicing on my skills
and then i take a break i like to
recharge like take a carbohydrate a
carbohydrate-rich drink protein-rich
drink give my body some nutrients and
then i like to maybe deadlift maybe i do
sit-ups maybe i do i'll change over um
create a lot of variety in my fitness
now i'm putting muscle on i'm developing
my athleticism
but to do let's say monday wednesday
friday athleticism tuesday
thursday jujitsu and then saturday jutsu
in my opinion you're only training jitsu
three times a week
i'm trading jutsu six times a week you
will never catch up to me
think about even if you just take one
day a week and you do fitness
and i take that one day a week i'm doing
shishitsu at the end of the year i have
50 classes more than you let's say you
take two weeks off for holidays or
whatever you're sick one week whatever i
have about 50 workout after three four
years i'm at hundreds of workouts more
than you
you will never catch up to me now
yeah you spoke about this on joe rogan
yeah it's just the numbers it's volume
at the end of the day i have more jiu
jitsu experience than you or boxing
experience whatever you want to call it
yeah
so i'm gonna as
just kind of clarify something you and
i'm gonna turn my camera off i'm gonna
try to set something up so i can my my
setup here charging so i don't die out
on you guys but just to clarify
uh number one
obviously your focal intention that's
gonna be the biggest determining factor
here so like if you're focusing on
your mma your skills and all that stuff
then your fitness has to be
geared towards that it can be geared
towards life
for instance power lifting hypertrophy
or
whatever the reason someone will be
weight training for maybe olympic
lifting or something like that
right but in in your experience thus far
of doing this
how has your results been in terms of
uh let's say strength potential and
let's say approach feed potential
while you've been training in this
aspect where you do your mma first and
then you might add in let's say the 10
sets of deadlifting
well think about it like this okay
there are many facets to fitness but
let's separate it in two just to make it
super simple
there's power and then there's endurance
i first have i have to have power and
then i want to keep that power going for
a long time hence endurance
i don't want to keep i don't want to
keep a weak love i don't want to have
this a weak level of power and keep that
going for a long time no no no i need a
lot of power
i need a lot of power on round one and
then i need endurance because i want to
have power in round three i want that
power to maintain i never want that
power to go down
and that's what fitness is about it's
about having a lot of power for a very
long time
every time i train power
sorry every time i train power fitness
goes down a little bit
that's how you think about it every time
i train 55
so what did i say power uh power uh then
fitness goes on you mean like endurance
yeah i'm sorry i'm an endurance part of
me every time i train power i do dead
lifts olympic lifts my endurance goes
down a little bit
every time i train endurance my power
goes down a little bit that's right so
we call this chasing your tail
so let's say i run every day for six
months
i'm running two miles a day for six
months
my endurance is gonna sorry my endurance
is gonna go up my power's gonna be down
here you're gonna go back on the squat
rack and be like hey i can't squat what
i used to squat yeah because you did a
lot of endurance your power goes down
how do we bring them both up
that's the key how do we bring them both
up well there are various methods i like
the conjugate method one day i'm working
one day i'm working on my power
sorry was that was that in the race one
day i'm working on my power the next day
i'm working on my endurance and yes my
power goes down a little bit but the day
after that i'm working on my power again
and then i'm working on my endurance and
i'm sawing them up slowly i'm i'm
bringing them from here i'm see-sawing
one up and then the other okay but
they're gonna see-saw back and forth how
do i know which one i need
well when i spar if i feel like round
one i'm taking guys down and i'm
punching really hard but after round
three i'm i'm i'm
dying out well i feel i need more
endurance
if in round one i feel i don't feel very
strong i don't feel like when i punch
i'm not really strong and i'm getting
tired that means you need power
so i'm a big believer in
low impact plyometrics done correctly
and i'm a big believer in interval
training
i think that these two
can help you build adequate levels of
power and adequate levels of endurance
and
incredible body composition
meaning high muscle low fat
so one thing i like to do after practice
i recommend you guys is just do a tabita
20 seconds of sprints
10 seconds rest repeat eight times
that's a very good way to build
uh endurance but it's also a power type
of endurance it's a it's a i like also
doing a 200 meter sprint one minute
break
yes i'm shooting up the heart rate
but i'm building an explosive type of
endurance okay it's always power
oriented and then some days i might do
olympic lift some days i might do bench
press sometimes i might do kettlebell
swing sometimes i might go heavy but i
fluctuate between the two i go endurance
power endurance power i never do just
power and i never do just endurance i'm
always doing the two and i'm surprising
my body every day i go in the gym and i
surprise my my body with it with a new
workout my body never knows i'm never i
never do the same workout twice
and why because i'm not trying to master
lifting weights i'm not trying to master
track and field i'm not trying to master
gymnastics i'm trying to master martial
arts so when i do my martial arts
routine i'm doing the same thing every
day and i'm ex i'm adding a new thing
here and there and then i drill it till
i know it i can do it in my my eyes
closed
i've rehearsed it i've greased the
groove i've made that movement so
i've done it so many times that when the
moment comes i'm gonna execute
when it comes to fitness i'm all over
the place why i never want my body to
adapt i want my body always to be um
surprised by the workout today i did
some uh
stretch band like i pulled up on a
stretch band i did kettlebell swing i
did some pull-ups i did some overhead
press
i'll never do that workout again
some days i do deadlifts with push-ups
sometimes i do deadlifts with the
medicine ball toss sometimes i do
deadlift with clean and jerk that's more
precise more power
i'll never do that same workout again
i'll use deadlift in a different type of
mix but i'll never really do that same
workout again i'm always surprising the
body with general fitness
and when it comes to my sport i'm doing
the same movements every day i'm making
them super precise
that's kind of like
aside from the mma training the uh
training that you do with
you know uh weightlifting or body weight
training and high intensity interval
training is very similar to intuitive
training where it's like
you're just kind of doing what like you
really feel is appropriate in the time
being for your body yeah you're right
you listen to your body and you see like
what do i feel that i need and what is
my goal you know i got to work backwards
i always recommend people
train first thing in the morning
make your peace with it you wake up
you do you make your salah and then you
train
or maybe you go back to bed but then
when you wake up for you have to make
time for training first thing in the
morning why
that's the most energy you have in the
day
once you wake up you brush your teeth
you have a little snack that's it that's
the max it's only downhill from here the
energy
now is the time and also when you train
in the morning you fire your metabolism
up for the rest of the day
you get the most bang for your buck
wake up in the morning i really
recommend kettlebell or body weight
training whatever if you're like a
nine-to-five or if you're if you're not
like in the gym every day like me you
don't have to
put a kettlebell in the corner of your
room wake up
don't pass that kettlebell without
training your training could be anywhere
from four minutes to 10 minutes to five
minutes
work out every day learn the pr learn
how to do
exercises precisely read the book supple
leopard i'll put the book in the um i
read the entire book by the way
this is a very important book
this is such an important book it
teaches you how to take care of your
body okay most people get injured when
they train they train incorrectly
if you train correctly
you will get fit
you will stay young
guys i'm 41 years old i still wrestle
with guys and they're
in their peak they're 21 years old
they've been training their whole life i
go in there and i wrestle with them
every single day i box with them every
single day i bring guys world class
fighters i train with them every single
day and we go we
we scrap
and i'm 41 years old there's very few 41
year olds who can do that
the secret is alhamdulillah the secret
is
training properly and it's not a secret
that i mean that book tells you how to
keep your body healthy
training consistently
and eating correctly that's also
something we should talk about eating
correctly super important
fitness there is no excuse make your
peace with it man you're gonna train
every day five to six times a week you
will train i don't care if your workout
is four minutes you got to do a tabata
at least a tablet a day
four minute workout like if you're not
gonna give your health four minutes man
like i don't know what to tell you i
don't care if it's burpees for four
minutes i don't care if it's squats for
four minutes and here is the key i want
you guys to all understand now here's
the key
don't overdo it go one step at a time
don't work out on monday and mess your
body up the tuesday you can't work out
work out 60 on monday until you get
comfortable with 60 and then you can
ramp it up to 70 and then 80 and then
85.
once you get to 85 you could fluctuate
between 80 and 95
but never go 100 on day one you know why
on wednesday your knee is going to be
hurting
on thursday your neck's going to be
hurting
on friday you're going to be oh my back
is sore i can't get out of bed well
guess what now we're not training
all this go hard or go home stuff is put
it in the garbage for a second okay
it's consistency over intensity
train every day eat well
and you won't age until you're in your
70s
guys i'm 41. my body works the same as
when i was 20. the body my body is the
same
it functions the same i have the same
level of energy i'm just older and wiser
but in the same body i still wear the
same clothes i don't have bigger size i
know you guys are young you're not
worried about this but believe me as you
get older you start it's gonna start
creeping up on you my joints are healthy
my neck is healthy my spine is healthy
everything is alhamdulillah
it's
becoming a supple leopard learning that
routine
taking care of your body
exercise first thing in the morning
eat
very well
so that kind of did in fact answer my
next question which was going to be when
i used to train in the morning
i was against that because i'd be forget
like not being able to train the next
day i couldn't do anything else that
same day i couldn't study i couldn't get
anything done i couldn't even make meals
i was like
no but then i thought about it i was
like you're right i'm going like 200
in the morning i always think look how
how do people become fat well eating is
pleasurable it's pleasure
i go to mcdonald's wow it's so good you
know you go to this restaurant oh the
food is so good so
you got to do the same thing but
backwards
your workout should make you feel good
i'm going to work out just enough that i
feel good
so here's the thing if you work out too
little
you didn't have any impact on you didn't
make you feel worse or better if you
work out too much think about goldilocks
the goldilocks if you work out too much
you're sore you're injured oh man i'm
torturing myself i'm making my life
miserable that's not gonna work either
in the long run you're gonna quit
if i train the right amount it has a
tonic effect a tonic effect is like when
you drink a coffee you feel more
energized
than before you started your workout
so let's say you wake up you're at a
seven
after your workout you feel like at
eight
meaning ten you're super charged up with
energy you just had five espressos
and one you're lethargic laying down on
the couch you just ate fried chicken you
feel horrible
food coma that's one
when you wake up if you're a six or a
seven after your workout you should cut
the workout when you feel like an eight
you should feel a high
exercise creates energy
the right amount excuse me let me
correct that the right amount of
exercise
creates energy
so if you wake up out of bed and you're
a seven of energy
and i make you do 20 30 jumping jacks
you're gonna go 7.2 7.5 then maybe i
make you hit the back i really believe
that you should shut up i love boxing as
a workout i love it boxing for one
minute then push-ups for one minute then
boxing for one minute then sit-ups for
one minute then lunges for one minute
then but like i like minute intervals i
really like that in the morning workout
because you don't need any equipment
now if you have a punching bag that's
even better i always say the best cardio
is bag
bag work
why because you you pump your heart you
work all your muscles you shed the fat
you burn the fat and it's fun and it's
also self-defense if one day you need it
boom you're packing the punch you've
been training that much if you ever need
to defend yourself you have a punch
there wait waiting for you like you you
can throw a punch okay it's a skill i
think every man should have
so your fitness
you know you go through your routine my
i'm fully charged now i'm ready for my
day i go and shower i brush my teeth i
feel amazing
however if you overdo it
you feel horrible you go to work and you
can't function well you overdid it now
you shot yourself in the foot i want to
work out just enough that tomorrow i
have some more
that is the secret to sticking
with
your fitness program because it becomes
addictive
if i don't train guys for two three days
i don't feel right i feel horrible i
don't know how people live
day to day without fitness
because i personally just don't feel
well
when i train too much i feel i feel
horrible i'm
like i'm hurting it's training there's a
goldilocks level for everybody and your
level will change as the fitter you are
the more dose you need it's like
somebody who takes a drug
after a few years they need more of that
drug to get the same high
well this is a positive high you need a
little more exercise well that's good
i'm getting fitter and i'm but i'm
getting that energetic tonic effect
so i highly recommend people work in
that goldilocks zone it's super
important and
if you take somebody who works in the
goldilocks zone
versus somebody who
goes big or go home type attitude kill
it or you know
that guy the guy who's the the you know
the bravado guy he trains a lot less
than the guy who trains in the
goldilocks zone at the end of the year
if you map if you if you count how much
they train how much energy they expend
how much they practice the guy in the
goldilocks zones faro does the guy who's
the
bite bite your teeth and grit through
now don't get me wrong a lot of athletes
do that
but you have to understand they have a
different motivation and they're doing
it for a short period of time like they
have a bout so they're waking up they
have that energy they wake up man oh man
i'm nervous about this fight and the
only thing that can calm those nerves
down
and
it's to train really really hard
and don't don't forget those guys have
years of experience from training before
they have these big fights for money
that they can take that amount of
training but if you take a regular guy
who's training at a at a c level and you
want to take him to an a plus level you
have to take him gradually
because if you don't you're going to
break him like he's literally going to
get injured he's going to break his knee
he's going to injure his neck like he's
going to break down he's not going to be
able to take that level of training for
a prolonged period of time it won't be
long before the guy starts telling you
look i have i need a surgery because you
broke my labor
or i dislocated my elbow like it's
something like if we're talking about
combat sports like it won't be long
before you get injured
so you gotta you gotta create a rhythm
and then of course when we have fights
we count down the weeks and we push it
even further but we're flirting with
injury yes we are but my point is why
flirt with injury if you're not fighting
for five hundred thousand dollars
like why flirt with injury
you know like
you're training for life like if i told
you hey guys you got to run for life are
you going to sprint
you're running for life so take your
time like like build pace yourself pace
yourself and you'll go a lot further
you'll cover a lot more miles
and once in a while of course we flirt
with
95
uh percent of
uh of of intensity
intensity is how hard you're going but
i'm not always at those intensities i
fluctuate back down you know i grapple
every day guys i go live every day
i know a lot of jesus guys they train
every day but they don't go live meaning
they don't wrestle every day it's just
like they go through
a lot of them do technique
they teach a private and then they lift
a little weight and they go home i go
live every day to go live every day if i
kill myself every day
it won't be long before i i'm totally
injured from head to toe you know so
it's just you got to train in a way
that's sustainable
all right
y'all got
the person has to number one put the ego
aside
number two
they can be you know a real structured
program because let's say
uh your program consists of you going to
the gym and you're going to be hitting
like five sets of pull-ups uh four sets
of uh
let's say dumbbell bench press and then
you got maybe dips or you got i don't
know something else right like having
this structure would then entail the
person saying oh well i got to finish
this exactly how it's saying
versus being intuitive like how i said
earlier you're having that intuitive
style of training because like you said
if you do
let's say three sets of pull-ups and
then you feel that heightened sense of
energy heightened sense of overall
well-being you could be like okay
i could finish right now
and that would be good and i know
tomorrow i could come in and do
something else
but then it's like there's always that
feeling like oh but i feel good right
now like let's keep going let's push a
little bit more
so like what what does that
realistically look like for someone
if they wanted to slowly increase their
workload and just be able to do more i
think i got a good answer for you
imagine let's think about the jump shot
you're playing basketball and you want a
jump shot you want to be the best three
point guy in the world
and you've decided that you're gonna
jump shot every day you're gonna do jump
shots every single day you're gonna work
on it you're not gonna be the best
dunker you're not gonna be the best
pastor you're not gonna be the best
rebound guy you're fascinated with three
point shot and you want everybody to
know you're the greatest three-point guy
in the world okay
if i was training you
i would make you do three point shots
every day
however
once your three pointers
dip below 70. so you're getting six out
of ten
that's the end of the
workout once your form starts to dip
so you feel good okay well shoot more
baskets i'm not gonna tell you to stop
you're on fire i'm not gonna tell you
stop
but once you dip below 70
you're scoring six out of ten if you're
at nine out of ten i'm not going to stop
you man keep going man have fun
when your body's tired there's going to
be a sign
when you're below 70 i know that if i
keep making you do jump shots
now i'm going to pollute your firing
sequences i'm you're teaching your body
to shoot the wrong way
i want to only do things the right way
i either do it the right way or i don't
do it at all why because if i do it the
wrong way
it's like if i've taught my body two
different ways to do it and my body's
like oh we're low on energy today run
this program that's how i see it
do the wrong one whatever that's what
we've learned i never allow my body to
do it the wrong way
as a matter of fact george st pierre one
of the greatest martial arts ever he
says he won't even watch a fight if the
guy doesn't fight well he's gonna avert
his eyes why he doesn't want to see even
show his body
somebody doing something wrong you know
i find that to be extreme
but i like to learn from everybody and
he is the greatest martial artist in
history
and like he used to walk up to me says
don't watch this fight the guy doesn't
fight well
but i want to watch it don't watch it he
tells me why it's going to give you bad
folds he tells me
it's going to give me and i think that's
ludicrous because i would never do what
he just did that guy
but in george shapiro's mind and i think
he may be right i may be wrong you know
i i'm hearing myself singing i think it
makes a lot more sense now that i say it
out loud when he told me that i thought
it was crazy but now that i'm saying it
to you guys i actually think it makes a
lot of sense i have to think about it
again
but he doesn't even want to watch a guy
who fights wrong he either you're going
to do it right or don't do it
so if you're doing your fitness your
pull-ups if you read the supple leopard
the guy's telling you this is how you do
a perfect pull-up it's how you do a
perfect dip
once you're below 70. guys it's time to
call the day the workout
time to call it save it for tomorrow so
whenever your form starts to dip
the weight is too heavy or you've done
too many reps
lower the weight or lower the reps
and if you can't and your form is still
off go home the workout is over tomorrow
is another day
and think long term so that's another
great way to think about fitness
never like i'll tell you guys something
today i was rolling
and after the second round i felt like i
was i was tired because i trained in the
morning so today my body it was taxed
okay let's just say needed a break i
took a break i took one round off so six
minutes seven minute break so the round
six minute one minute breaks i took
seven minutes i went back and i did
another roll and now i was charged up
again so i was above 70 of my capability
but if my capability ever dips below 70
i stop the workout i skip the next round
i recharge or i go home
so i want you guys to always remember
that you never want to be
doing your boxing workout looking like
this
like you never want to push yourself
that far that you look like a drunken
master you know what i mean or whatever
you're doing it's either be done right
or
lower the intensity lower the difficulty
or take a break and recharge and do it
again or go home but don't work
in
a sloppy fashion
understood
amazing answers man so i guess the only
question that i would have the last one
is like how do you deal with injuries
you know because i've had a groin injury
for a few months now man
and martial you know i'm not i'm not
upset because i've learned a lot through
this
it's taught me a lot
but i would you know i'm trying to heal
back up to get back into mma
so that's my question well
if you look at the kelly starts work in
the the book becoming a supple leopard
he says it's two things injuries is
usually these two things one
it's uh you're you're unaligned there's
a structural issue you have you need
alignment and two
there's a tight muscle so if you're uh
misaligned you're gonna create some
tension in the system your your muscles
gonna be tight
no human being can be out of alignment
and be loose so we need to always
correct alignment and then we have to
make the muscle supple as he says okay
so you need to need you need to need the
muscles and he says you need to need the
muscles below and above it not only the
muscle that hurts but the ones below it
and above it and then he tells you how
to straighten your body how to
neutralize your spine how to neutralize
your neck
how to sit how to stand how to walk how
to move your body
in an aligned fashion
and you will quickly see that your pains
will subside
but you have to follow the program so i
would go to chapter seven where he tells
you how to work on your groin area
i would do those exercise and i would go
into the part where he talks about how
to walk how to climb up how to walk
upstairs how to sit properly and you'll
notice that aligning your body all the
time correctly
will lead to a pain-free body
and believe me i know all about pain
believe me like uh
you know i've had it all i've had neck
injuries knee injuries groin injuries
back hamstring because you can't avoid
injuries per se but you have to know how
to take care of them and you can you
can't avoid them at 100 that's what i'm
trying to say you can minimize them
and
you can treat them
before they become chronic so if you
have something that's hurting you for
over a year now it's becoming chronic
like you've let it go too far you got to
kind of kill it when it's young and it's
just starting so me every time i feel
like
something's tight in my body or i feel a
pain somewhere i take care of it until
it goes away i don't let it become a
monster
so
in your
in your thought pattern do you think
that when you have a certain injury like
let's say
i idea ideologically here
if we have
a groin injury
do you think that it's not really the
the groin that's the problem but more so
the
uh opposing muscle group so you would
have
the the groin is that the adductor or
the abductor i always get those two
mixed up i'm not sure i always get this
those get the abductor in that doctor
okay so you have the muscle that's part
of the glute and it's um i think it's
called the glute medius the one that
like brings your leg out
so would you think that it would be a
result of a weak glute medius and maybe
something else as weak as cause it can
be
we're never sure so that's why i love
what kelly started says it says try it
on one side try it on the other and
always do the opposite muscles as well
so he's telling you look hit that area
he calls it up above stream and below
stream don't just hit the target hit
below it hit above it
hit the opposite muscles
and spend your time kneading that area
and sometimes you're going to find that
trigger point you're going to hit a
point you're like wait a second i'm
hitting this point
and i feel it in going up to my groin
okay well this could be connected so you
massage it out and he says look you
always have two sides so try the other
side if you don't have the same trigger
point on the other side that makes sense
that that could be the start of your
problems like for instance i was having
one of my students on the on the mat
today he had injured his toe really
badly he had an inflamed toe
and i was telling him how he should
treat that and also telling him be
careful because if you don't take care
of that toe it's going to creep up into
your knee because the joints below
support the joints above
so if you're joined below if you're if
you're compensating because of an
injured toe the knee is always out of
position now you don't have alignment so
how can we be sure where the problem is
well kelly basically tells you look hit
that whole general area
and always test the other side it will
give you an idea
and work it until it disappears you know
work until you have no more pain
work above work below work both sides
and look be
be
on the lookout for those trigger points
points where you're touching like ah
that's something not normal okay massage
that out
take care of it till it's no more
and you know it's really important take
care of the body because the body
the body is a very important uh medium
to feeling good
you know if you have back pain neck pain
it harms the quality of your life you
know it harms the quality of energy and
vitality you have
to be fit
is one of the greatest human experiences
you feel
energetic you feel you have vitality you
feel alive you feel good you feel
optimistic
you feel
energized when faced with a problem you
know what i have the energy to deal with
this
being run down and having pain it's very
it can put you in a dark state of mind
over time
if the brothers don't have anything else
to ask
i figured i'd ask one last question
uh go for it because i feel like your
question is relevant to what we're
talking about now because i wanted to
talk about eating
yeah we should talk about dieting i
think it's a very important topic as
well
okay do you
want me to ask this last video yeah
of course of course go for it okay so
if someone wants to get good at fighting
obviously
they have to they have the train
sure they have to train
now a few things that they could do is
perhaps uh observation you know monkeys
do they watch professionals fight uh
they watch a lot of skill work maybe
slow down the videos
keep watching it repetitively
um
what are some other things these people
could do though
to be able to
i guess you could say progress
at a much more rapid pace if they're
also doing all the uh
you know the the dotting their eyes and
crossing their teeth here
um you know i'll tell you that
i think about my sport a lot so i like
you know every time i learn a move or i
learn a sequence i think i go over it in
my mind a lot
and i think that's a major help because
when you're rehearsing the moves in your
mind you eventually start to think about
them at a at a more
at a deeper level you know and then you
start to almost connect dots you know
like oh this system works
together with this other sequence you
know like i don't know you could learn
it you can learn a guillotine sequence
and then you learn armbar sequence and
you kind of put them together and if the
guy escapes your armor he falls into the
guilty and if the guy skips the guilty
and he falls into the r bar and you just
start you start realizing it's a whole
system of of
of problem-solving
solutions and you start to see it as a
whole and i think it makes you more um
intelligent in the ring you have a
higher fight iq so to say uh so
observation is one physical training is
one but also mental rehearsal like just
going over the moves just thinking about
them hey how does this move work why
does the guy fall when i trip him this
way what makes him fall like
understanding the principles behind it i
think it makes for a much more creative
and uh enlightened uh uh fighter
well i said
thank you
bro
all right so hey bro go ahead die
bismillah so
let's keep uh the pareto principle in
mind the 80 20. just give us the most
high-yield things that our lay audience
might want to know that want to take
their
body to i guess the sunnah physique keep
everything cool
um and it doesn't need to be exactly
what you're currently doing it's just
what you recommend for majority of the
lay population that's crazy because
y'all know how like impactful it was
yeah isn't it if you're watching this it
was so it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because how strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subhanallah i think it's crazy that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]